hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to
three scary games
please enjoy this sound
thank you for listening please enjoy the
video
welcome to scp-087 if you want a blast
from the past
in the description i've linked a video
that i did way back in 2012 when i first
played
like the original version of scp-087
which if you don't know what scp-087
is go check that out you'll see baby
markiplier
playing this game but this is apparently
a good version of it man i haven't
played much scp lately
i miss it i miss it a lot i think they
discontinued the unity project
which is sad but oh well we're going to
play this one
oh right into it stop
playing document 0874 exploration 4
radio comms something something
hello so if you don't know what it's
about
you should read the original article
it's very much about this stairwell
scp-087 is an unlit platform staircase
located on the campus of redacted
a light source is required for subjects
exploring scbo at 7.
lightning swords brighter than 75 watts
have shown to be ineffective oh
the bottom of sp07 it exists has not yet
been discovered i've discovered it
at least in the game that i played i did
eventually make it down to the bottom
spoilers everybody but i did it on a
live stream
what's at the bottom i won't tell you
for yourself anyway
hello hello
oh yeah so
if it wasn't clear we're not alone in
the stairwell
oh no no
oh god it's something about it
it's a primal terror it's so simple and
yet so effective
you just don't want to go down and yet
the only thing you can do is go down
it's an almost perfect oregon
[Music]
reports having distress crying and
vocalization what sounds like a child
between the ages of blue and blue
however any attempts to send circus has
failed to bring subject closer to the
show through crying
i don't hear any crying i don't hear any
crying at all
is it crying or singing is it crying or
singing
i don't know which i'd prefer like a
siren song drawing me down
no it's crying um
you can do the sound of crying yeah i
know i am aware of what my ears are
hearing
yeah i can hear that okay can i go now
oh you estimate that the source is
around six flights down
i estimate that well let's get down to
it then
am i crazy or did i see something float
up there in the corner of my vision
it might have just been the staircase
and i didn't notice it but i'm pretty
sure i saw something
after i see poa7's discovery multiple
expirations for conducting
infrastructure yeah
the first step recording was shown to be
far beyond both the possible structure
of the building and geological
blah-blah-blah at this time it is
unknown if scp-087 has an endpoint
is it unknown is it
okay
oh
i saw that i knew i saw something it's
the face
it's the face face the freaking face
oh the face hole in the wall
yeah uh-huh there's a hole in this wall
look into the hole
this is a bad idea i'm going in
it's too dark to see anything yep
i figured oh
no why is there an arrow puppy
hey what's up it's me again it's too
dark to see anything
yeah sure is what if i go no i just go
away then
okay cool yeah that's good oh this is
good
oh
i saw that i saw that
a rock a rock fell a rock
a rock a rock
oh fun rock a loose piece of concrete
has broken off and falling down
i already said all of that in less words
oh it's grimy down here oh
oh grimy
oh hey you know that that doesn't spook
me anymore
anymore that doesn't spook me anymore
it's gonna take a lot more than that to
spook the likes of me
let me tell you that i tell you me
hey what's up buddies what's up buddy
not scary not scary not scary not scary
not scary
well that's new but also not scary
each subject in conducting animal
explorer encountered sp0871
scp-087-1 appears to be a face with no
visible pupils nostril or mouth
the nature of spo-871 is entirely
unclear but it has been terminated
i wish i could read those you guys can
read those because you can pause the
video with anything
it's fine
why am i doing this
yep it's blood all right all right
carrying on that was fun
who the hell do you think you are
recording was i not recording before i
don't remember that blinking like that
before
recording recording hi hole hey
there's a hole in this wall yeah
oh i suppose it was supposed to be
scarier
lixie and make it scarier for everybody
watching at home
you recover you pick up the camera and
continue i continue down or do i go back
straight up
look into the hole yeah look in the hole
yeah i'll look in the hole
all right whatever man you messed up my
camera man
not my camera man i'm i'm the cameraman
but you messed up my camera comma
man hey stop it
stop it stop it
oh hell oh good
i was hoping
i was really hoping oh i was really
hoping
oh ah oh what is that
what is it
oh i'm gonna get speared up the paint
good no thank you i don't know if i
touch these and i die but i'm just not
gonna i'm not gonna try
oh oh oh oh no thank you
no thank you no oh
hi hi oh don't do that don't do that
whatever you're doing don't do that
no what pieces of long hair-like
material are reaching up from the ground
oh they're just hairs
oh all right then we'll uh due to the
results of the final explanation
exploration four note personnel are
permitted access to scp-087 oh i'm that
that's me that's me
i'm number four oh
hi oh
[Music]
that is good only observed in
exploration for a strange organic
material covers a wall deep within 087
uh it's possible that sp007 of the
living structure absorbing feeding off
the organic material inside it
shortly afterwards except for the
subject dropped the video camera as they
were in capacity
oh god here comes the unknown force oh
blood from the ceiling
oh hey buddy oh god why
how did you recover the camera oh here i
go oh the hairs
oh the faces oh my ass
uh no no
oh god soon if the camera's dropped
signal contact eventually deteriorated
into static due traveling out of range
oh over a period of two weeks falling
exploration several members of the
who are knocking coming from the
interior the door leading in scp-07 has
been fitted with six centimeters similar
to
all reports of knocking a ceased oh my
god
what was that what did i just see
good job i did i did i never realized
how important that star was to me thank
you
that was great really great really
really great i almost want to play the
original
scp-087b just because i want to compare
it but
i won't because you guys can go check
out the video and it can live
in the time that it was and you can see
me
like nine years ago so link for that is
in the description if you want to see it
there's tons of sap stuff
there's so much scp stuff if you haven't
seen any of my scp videos like there's
just an
enormous amount of sap content games and
people that love the universe
just really cool stuff so go check it
out it's all very good
very good moving on
this is night guard where i'm a
night guard wowzed you got it
i'm a night guard oh yeah my favorite
shot night guard
another boring night another horror
movie
yes i know
that seems pretty cool
the what happened
maybe i should check the fuse box that
always works out well for the likes of
me
med kit a meow kit
an office phone a trashy can a chair
a cup of coffee
where am i oh
oh i'm gonna like the parking garage in
resident evil too
weird or just a parking garage you know
there actually are parking garages
outside of that video game
in real life
hi hello
hi oh i did not expect that to open
hi is there a fuse box right here a box
of fuses
anybody seen a fuse box just a fuse
yeah one of the most useful tools in the
world yeah
[Music]
a medkit yeah just a toolbox
duct tape fix almost anything
i'm stuck
[Music]
okay
all right hello
hello damn it looks like the fuse is
blown
i need to replace it okay
i saw a fuse over here is it going to be
that simple
yep i'm sure this will allow me to go
back to my movie
with no consequences or problems
or demons or nightmares or
horrors from the beyond
did that do the opposite oh no no no
it's good
that's good
what is that sound is it the front door
okay yeah okay
hey you need permission to be here
i'm the night guard for some reason
guarding these
cars hello
hello yeah this doesn't seem to go
anywhere
hello hello
i don't see anything
oh oh i'm the door is closed okay
good bad very bad hello
i should call the director i have not
the keys
what the hell
what one
oh my god sounds like a baby no it does
not sound like a baby what kind of baby
you heard what kind of demon baby you
ever hear okay i need a screwdriver or
duct tape
when tool breaks one tool fixers the
power of the universe and creation in
the bottom of my hand
and then this quote unquote baby in this
trunk
hi
yep good idea here
oh good
good good
i don't have any thoughts about this all
right thoughts about this
no it's a toy what's going on let's
check the fuses
yeah i should yeah yeah i should i would
i would if i could
it'd be good if i could and i would if i
should but i won't
and i will i'll do it
hi you're not supposed to be here
i don't like that i can hear that baby
so loudly
oh someone shat in my fuse box
power surge the fuse box is completely
blown these boxes blown i can't fix it
not even with duct tape maybe with duct
tape
if it's almost anything okay
[Music]
well the baby's quiet now that's good
baby how you doing oh baby had a lot of
blood in it
that baby was like a big old blood bag
oh no
there's a bass guitar player over in the
darkness
stop twanging
[Music]
stop slapping it oh i did not do that
i'm being framed uh want your language
ow
i feel like there were a lot less
elaborate ways to kidnap me
than to leave an entire trail of blood
from a baby
in the back of a trunk and a knife in it
i was literally watching a movie you
could have
wamped me from the get-go but i
appreciate the elegance
it made me feel very important that you
went through all that trouble to kidnap
me
not bad a good spook at the end there
really made me scooch
i don't know what that means
oh my god what the hell is that
i never i've never seen that before in
my life
what the hell was that okay welcome to
dispatch
this game uses voice recognition and
directional audio what
i'm sorry
what your password i don't know what my
password is here
nice nice nice nice i did it
nice oh god no god no
no no
what minor incident status resolved
woman was cooking pancakes for her
partner and some butter splashed onto
young man shot and killed an attempted
robbery outside
and grieving grieving partner was
my partner's dead oh
hello oh someone's calling 9-1-1 i'm
dispatch hey there son
oh no son i noticed that you haven't
been filling out the reports on the
calls you've been doing recently
listen i know that you must be pretty
torn up about what happened and
like i said to you before this isn't on
you
no one's blaming you i wasn't blaming me
he shouldn't have gone in the way he did
he should have waited for the right
people to come and
like i said no one's blaming you for
that
right no one's blaming me just
don't stay in all night again and just
fill out the reports on your calls
okay you got it buddy you got to pass
better
yeah um yeah okay we'll do
thank you love you bye
fill up the reports how do i fill out
the reports what reports am i filling
out
oh 9-1-1 what's your emergency we need
an ambulance quick
okay uh calm down tell me what's
happened
he's going to die oh god how could i let
this happen
i don't know what happened who's going
to die gus is
gus okay he's eaten a whole snickers bar
is he allergic to nuts well no
but dogs aren't supposed to have
chocolate are they
oh it'll be fine just call that
all right fine minor emergency
let's see miner a dog
ate chocolate
oh was i supposed to be writing that as
i was on the call i have no idea
wait a minute what the hell
that wasn't open before that was most
certainly not open before
hi 911 what's your emergency finally i
was beginning to think i would never get
an answer
what 911 what's your emergency that
wasn't much of an apology
what's the emergency i am being forced
out of this shop
we got an unwillingly ago man
i am a paying customer and you cannot
force me to leave
what's your name you don't have the
right to know my name
the caller is being asked to leave
a shop after closing i'm sorry i cannot
help you useless i will be calling your
manager
first thing in the morning
my my manager
that'd be service my my manager
my my manager wait my fault i don't what
is that
zoom zoom more
more what is that
what is that zoom what is that
something moving in the distance what is
that yeah yeah yeah i don't know what's
your emergency
hello someone is trying to get into my
house
okay all right what's your address it's
54 raymond street
uh-huh yeah who they are it's got to be
my ex-husband
okay what is he doing he's been banging
on the windows and calling out for me
he's not allowed to be here
is he being threatening he's trying all
the doors and asking to see her
okay asking to see who sophie
she's our daughter she lives with me he
gets visits
uh okay i'll get a unit out on the way
to help calm things down
oh no he's broken in
tell him to hurry okay all right the
unit is on the way calm down are they
going to take
i don't know they're they're only a
couple of minutes
maybe sometimes you may have to confront
him come on where are you
i'm going to give the phone to my
daughter and try to talk to him
oh maybe that wasn't the best idea all
right but if he's aggressive go to your
daughter
stop until he finds her
pass me to your daughter
hello hello hello what's your name
sophie
who are you this is extremely
uncomfortable i'm a police officer i'm
helping your mom and dad
my dad is here he said he was gonna come
last week
but he didn't do you know why you didn't
i'm
i'm not sure nine minutes
but they would shout a lot sometimes
i think it was because of me
[Music]
uh they both love you though
i don't give a damn about the police all
i care about right now is we're sophia
oh no they're shouting again
uh it's okay where are you in the house
i'm
i'm down downstairs in the living room
okay where are your parents they're
they're breaking things in the kitchen
can you
can you stop them that is horrible we
can but i need to get upstairs
okay i'm gonna run past them and go into
my room
no no wait no wait bad idea
sophie oh
it stop it let her go
five minutes hello
oh god oh there's stuff behind me
oh sophie are you okay my dad just
wait my mommy mom
sophie where are you
hi
your dad hurt your mom yes yes he pushed
her
and now she's bleeding oh
okay i'm not a professional
where are you now i'm upstairs in my
room i can't
i can hear him breaking stuff
does your door have a lock in it no but
i could put a chair in front of it mom
did it once
okay do it quietly and stay home what is
she doing
i can't smell smoke you can smell smoke
i think hmm think he's upstairs
push the chair against the door oh all
right um i'll try
i'm putting the phone down come on hurry
up
oh man hi come on in
[Music]
stop circling the block and just go
there man
this is messed up
no no
i just think he's gone his smoke is
getting
really bad
uh can you hear the sirens yet yes i
i can hear them outside yes please
please
choose to help dispatch this is unit
8908 approaching the property now
we need fire services here asap
okay the child is trapped inside
how about is the fire it's pretty bad
looks like it started on the first floor
where's the kid uh in a room blocking
the door
we might be able to get in and out in
time if we knew which room she was in
uh sophie i need you to go to the window
and open it
no there's too much smoke just
tell them to come and find me
go to the window they'll be able to
figure out where you are please trust me
okay
okay i'm going to do it good job well
done please be quick i
see her stay there kid we're coming
hey is that good that feels good that
feels like i did good
good oh no it's not good
oh hi how you doing come here kid
i got you it's all right
we're getting out of here hi i did a
good
do i get a pass hi oh
[Music]
i love that i was engrossed i haven't
used the word
engrossed in a while but i was engrossed
with that that was great
that was wonderful that was fantastic i
feel like the sound design could have
used a little bit of work overall but
other than that
the experience of being like a 9-1-1
dispatch
person it's just like
you know what i mean it's like and i bet
there's alternate endings where you
don't do so good
i don't think i did that great in the
first place but just like i would love a
full game like this
i would love a full game like this that
was so
immersive it was just so immersive i
really really
can't overstate how much i enjoyed that
detected mike
yeah what was it what hey
my microphone works so close this window
oh wait that's not even the right
mic oh that's not even the right one it
wouldn't have worked in the first place
the voice recognition not necessary but
just like
it is kind of cool but the options are
fine too great
stuff love it at that lover to that
love it to that i love it to that
hey that was three scary games thank you
guys so much for
watching love you love everything you do
love everything about you you're so good
in every single way
thank you so much for being a part of
this channel and not watching my videos
really means the world to me hey you
have a lovely day out there
you have a lovely time nothing but uh
kindness and love
being sent your way so you have a good
night you have a good night i'll watch
over you
[Music]
you